cuéntenos que deberían hacer los
gobiernos para evitar que esto pase
deberían legalizar se las drogas para
tener mayor control sobre lo que se
produce
buenas tardes muchísimas gracias por el
espacio
bueno es una inclusión bastante compleja
nacionalistas así que voy a tratar de
hacer lo más concisa posible que es que
el ambiente actual legal e institucional
para abordar la problemática de drogas
en todo el mundo que es en las políticas
previsionistas abstencionistas la guerra
contra las drogas es un fracaso rotundo
sobre evidencia científica que que pone
de manifiesto el fracaso de estas
políticas tanto para controlar al
narcotráfico y reducirlo y combatirlo
sino también para reducir el uso de
drogas en la población mundial que no
para de crecer
hay un 30% más de usuarios de sustancias
activas en el mundo que hace 10 años así
que por lo menos en argentina creemos
que el paso inmediato fundamental es
despenalizar la tenencia de drogas
porque hoy en día todas las políticas
julia nuestro país son apuntadas a
perseguir a usuarios y consumidores
despilfarrando muchísimos recursos
básicamente y ahora cuál es el panorama
sobre el consumo y la venta de drogas en
argentina y de dónde proviene
bueno la verdad depende de qué sustancia
estemos hablando es distinto hablar del
mercado de cannabis en argentina que en
el mercado de este de psicodélicos y
estimulantes como con la cocaína en el
caso particular que estamos hablando
ahora este insisto es un rama con el
complejo cada mercado tiene su
particularidad el tema del cannabis por
ejemplo argentina está dando pasos
bastante acelerados en pos de la
regulación del mercado actualmente hay
un marco legal que permita a las
personas utilizar el cannabis
terapéutico de manera legal pero con
respecto al resto de las drogas la única
política público ofrece el estado hoy es
a través del código penal a través de la
persecución de las personas usuarias lo
cual maximiza y agranda los problemas
este porque ésta es evidente que se va a
trabajar se les usuarios nunca se va a
solucionar el problema de las drogas